and today
going to explore kind of the beginnings
of
the the the projects that that that
i i've been kind of questioning designed
through
um in in particular a few years ago
while working on a book project and so
that that for me starts with this this
sort of underlying idea of what stories
are are underpinning design so what are
the methods that
then might be possible if we as
designers were to tell
those stories differently so this sort
of interlocking focus on how we would
play
what we do and tell and communicate that
and the things that we build and their
impacts on the world
so for for much of my training this
these questions um were kind of
present and part of the the
research in in sort of design and
computer science hci
through uh very widely celebrated
scholars and ideas
conceptualized by john dewey herbert
simon donald trump people who had so
much to
offer a design field in terms of the
kinds of like
collaborations and work to undo a very
extractive
relationship with environment and space
but also who had
limited things to say about the more
hegemonic and patriarchal legacies
of the field so one thing that that
has been stunning and exciting to see is
is the
range of texts that um
i i find inspiring on the daily basis
have come out in the last few years
that really challenged some of those
those kind of
more more uh
limited perspectives um on what design
is and who it impacts and why so in
particular
um scholars that are thinking about the
kinds of
grossly une uneven forms of
representation
of contributions to computing regimes
and
are chronicling this through a sense for
what futures are possible
when we account for our past
um and a few people have have
been particularly notable and my
thinking in this
in this space um in particular uh
historian sadia hartman's work
in terms of the the kinds of ways she is
coined the phrase critical fabulation in
which the book
described michael just mentioned came
about
who speaks about the the writing against
an archive right so an archive is a
collection of documents that
represents a history a particular point
of view
but from her vivid essay venus into acts
she describes what it means to narrate
the impossible so that is
a kind of story from uh the example of
an enslaved woman venus that has
no known or knowable
story that kind of gap in the archive
means for her representing a sequence of
events it calls
for attempting to jeopardize the status
of the event displacing a received or
authorized account and imagining what
might have happened
what might have said or what might have
been done
more recently uh just this this
last few months you might have seen a a
really powerful text by catherine matin
mckin
mckittrett came out through uh
a sort of encounter between
cultural geography and black studies
that she has
spent time thinking through sylvia
winter's work
and department as well as others and
exploring the role of storytelling in a
dif
in a kind of complementary sense where
stories
are not answers she says stories offer
an aesthetic
relationality that relies on dynamics of
creating
narrating listening hearing reading
sometimes
unhearing so this is really about also
um
challenging this this engagement uh uh
with with a kind of a
radical engagement um that that involves
care and and connection
over a kind of exclusion inclusion
politics
so a very different relationship between
those
that are are involved in the work of
producing science and engineering
and this this may seem far-fet
far from the hci space but today i'm
going to try and
tie it in with two projects two specific
engineering feats so something that we
might
um celebrate as as innovations
um within design legacies so apollo
and atari and specifically thinking
about
how we can take inspiration from these
stories through design
and what i want to explore here are
are two phases of this this process so
one
is looking what it's like to expose um
the kind of
erasures in in our stories and then the
other
focusing on what kinds of design
processes
uh affect and shape the world in which
those stories are told
so the retelling so the first story
begins
uh with a kind of short few
seconds uh clip of a documentary
mini series that came out in 2008 and
here
you see this this um picture of two
people who who appear to be women with
rolled up sleeves
in a kind of factory setting who are um
passing a kind of needle back and forth
through a grid of
holes so when and to me and maybe
um to some of you this this process
actually resembled something
like weaving so there was a a leasing of
threads in orthogonal directions
creating a kind of textile fabric
but here in this setting you see that
the weavers are
using unconventional materials such as
magnetic rings
wire and odd-shaped loom and
they appear to be in a very unusual
space
for what you might think of as uh
textile creations um in the sense of the
machinery surrounding them
now over the scene you see uh a
the voice of a managing director at this
at the
factory this is richard batten who says
clearly we called this process the lol
method
says the little old lady method of
wiring course
so essentially this footage which uh you
know
i came across during phd studies
studying the intersection
of fabric and computing i was interested
in how this few seconds long clip
became actually one of the only
surviving accounts
of the women who physically wove the
software
for the apollo missions during the 1960s
so this is a a a process
of creating what was called core memory
um during the the 50s and 60s this was a
principle mechanism by which computers
were storing and retrieving information
so it was a physical distinction
that was created where pictured here you
see core memory rope
passing the wire through the rope
creates the one while bob bypassing it
creates
the zero and that design of a core
memory came at a time
where the computing industry looked
radically different right we have these
massive machines
heavy um running on punch cards
sort of filling up a room that dominates
the industry
now contrasting with with those room
size space
mechanics you see this the need for
essentially
a a
a a cone rocket sorry
some some kind of um code that needed to
fit inside
that that cone of that rocket so it's a
it's a very particular setup
right where you have extreme
temperatures
extreme vibrations limited electricity
um and essentially uh every part of the
weaving of these cores
met these constraints so
when we hear the story of this this feat
of apollo the first mission to the moon
and back
with people on board the these stories
of apollo via visa v people
like neil armstrong are not telling
this story are not telling the stories
of this particular process right
what we hear about the process are told
about
i'm told by the people that are managing
directors
like richard batten
so to explore this vis-a-vis design
the process began exploding in front of
us
i began working with samantha shorey
communication scholar as well as
um helen remick and brock kraft
and wider um group of folks
interested in this development of
computing
and and stories about that process so we
began looking through the
the archives at different formations of
core memory as they
developed into what's called poor memory
planes
and formed informing the design
of of eventual core memory rope
but also involving even smaller weaving
instruments
and microscopes and while collecting the
initial materials
i came across a small number of planes
online and ordered them and held them in
our hands and this was the moment of
connection
so in our hands those planes actually
felt
a kind of con sort of a symmetry with
the
shape size of an oddly complementary
mode of memory production and that
memory production was that
of quilting so over the coming months
we collaboratively built a quilt made up
of the core memory planes those patches
that would materialize
that work of of the core memory weavers
as well as
pose new points of encounter so we
worked um
in in development across a series of
patents
across electronic textiles materials
old telephone wire that was repurposed
as forms of
quilting process and thinking about how
this feminized legacies of practice
could be casted
we re reworked and undone through this
hardware manufacturing process
so then during a series of workshops we
took
uh a a
kind of approach at opening this the
quilt itself and invited groups of
historians of technology
design educators and members of the
public to
um who are visiting maker faires and
such were
interested in the assembling of what we
eventually called
patch kits so these kits were comprised
in
the board loom and strings in place of
the
cores and wires and each became a kind
of future quilt square
so once assembled those patches acted as
tools to explore an archive of media
materials
firsthand accounts of core memory
production that we collected along the
way
so you would plug in the assembled patch
into the quote
and hear allowed oral accounts of core
memory production from our archive
materials but then you'd also
be tweeting those materials from the
twitter account
lol weavers which was a sort of attempt
to reflect the same number of characters
that were once held by each core memory
plane but also to
matriculate these stories of water
audiences
so for example one of the quotes read
the female operators were good at it
and those that stood around telling them
what to do were terrible at it
it's from edwin wadden so soon that
conversation turned to the language that
we used to describe
the process of making core memory and
how that process compared to
the engineers themselves so one when
asked
what that what that kind of
mode that i called weaving earlier was
assigned within
um core memory land uh literatures and
and the folks that were managing
i turned to a man named frederick dill
who had been
in touch with and had been an engineer
and co-inventor of the
semiconductor laser and
had sent me a beautiful typed and
written note
along with the book um digital computer
components
and circuits and his note read until the
discussion i'd never heard of stringing
cores as a weaving problem
but it's certainly a good view
now to understand what he meant by this
i followed up an email and he told me
well when i was at what what you have
done is
focus on the threads the wires where i
focused on the cores
i looked at the wires through the cores
in terms of what electrical signals they
provided
what voltages cured at their ends and
from various electrical currents
through the single core array of cores i
could see how the wires
were passed through the cores and your
focus on weaving is an equally valid
viewpoint
but at different ones it sort of assumes
that some particular configuration of
weaving will produce what is needed
which is totally correct
so in paying attention to weaving
alongside the electrical cores
themselves we were seeing these
these layers of of of production and
unable to explore
and highlight the laboring bodies
alongside
the things that that they were producing
so in highlighting those different
stories of embodied practice we're also
identifying the weave as that pivotal
innovation
which uh dill said was what produced
what was needed
so this insight is is highly unusual
because
it is fully admitted from the core
memory literature but
also it recognizes embodied practice or
bodies at
all as part of um the
the the contribution the key
contributions to engineering and this is
something that
uh our collaborator helen remick picked
up in the quilting of
of the object itself in which she said
quilting isn't just hand work
it's back work it's neck work it's knee
work
and the process of building apollo was
all those things as well
so now exploring this kind of uh
sort of exposure of of erasures
and and exploring it in a material
fashion was a
a a kind of a lead into a second project
that led was led by
pranilla bjorn in a class that we
co-taught
on the study of atari and i'm going to
walk through how that particular
classroom experience um which we kind of
directed research
group was able to produce a series of
interesting
um encounters with the atari legacy
so in this very different context um
the the team included um
and a number of students that were
taking taking this
this course with us and this series of
events
that um were scaffolded after the course
so these included
emerald city comic con exit a full
exhibition at the
living computer museum in seattle and
a fashion show in the heart of seattle's
pioneer square
so where we started was actually with
this particular
notion of of design and
in recognition within the atari legacy
if you if you remember atari it was a
gaming console that that was um
instrumental in the early arcade video
computer
gaming industries um it was a
corporation
that produced the gaming console i
should say that was formed in 1972
and then it lasted well into the 80s so
and the kind of the kind of company
stories that get told
um are are
pretty exciting on the one hand stories
of pong these early games that animated
many of
uh those of us that that have been drawn
into
computing fields but they also tended to
leave out several stories
or to depict them in very limited
fashion so when we began sort of
exploring the wikipedia documents and on
archival materials primary secondary on
atari
it was clear that people that present as
women
are excluded from many of those stories
um when they do appear they they are
often depicted with
um very limited explanations so for
example a few texts mentioned
don epstein or beth tycho by name these
are particular
story uh atari contributors but there
was no mention of their contributions
um these are the erasures then and that
inspired our project
so um across the series of months as i
explained we we developed
uh exhibitions and particular
um design artifacts that and that were
then
part of the events the panels and the
other engagements that we created
the first of these was a simple
reworking of the
brand itself so an initial intervention
took that atari a logo and
infused it with the the image of a
silhouette of
the sort of upward looking to the right
empowerment
for a second um sort of a
complementary story we explored each of
the
the the interviewees that pernilla
engaged with through a a kind of
visual visual mark so we created
simplified
low resolution images that represented
each character
um and their or each speech each
character
or antagonist in the game that was
produced vis-a-vis
the atari women
those then sort of uh
provided the the groundwork for a larger
poster
that was in celebrating their particular
story
as um the centipede for example which
donna bailey
um was responsible for for developing
with a team
um in the early game really coin-op
consoles chrismatic um
rebecca heinemann is the space invader
graphic etc where
she she was the first esports game
championship
um for the particular pac-man
so so organizing this around more
material forms
we took those those uh graphics which
were produced as
posters and other paraphernalia
brochures into a kind of gaming
genre of the token which is uh the kind
of coins used in early arcade games
reflecting that legacy and intertextual
relation
um so those were concrete artifacts that
could serve as kind of collectibles
in our encounters a fourth
of uh specific uh piece was this
uh organized the sort of e-tech style
intervention where our efforts to
connect with comic-con which is a very
um kind of cosplay-centric uh
conference cosplay refers to a
performance art
where people create costumes dress up
their favorite characters
um and often characters from games
movies comics and then we'll sort of
celebrate that that's
the gaming culture so this in this
costume the atari logo was wired up with
multi-colored led strips
and created these blinky rainbows so
this is really about engaging
the the students themselves and how they
represent their interests in the stories
that
um have recorded through through these
world history accounts
now the the kind of follow-up to this
ism
is is actually in the the surprising
moments
that that sort of um i encounter
through through the interview enabled so
for example suki li who worked at apple
had brought up an interview a colleague
who had who um was
actually posting of his his discovery
um on social media writing i bought a
bunch of atari games today but
while i was reading up on them i found
one of them was written by my team's
current
pm it's like i've been working next to
royalty without even knowing it
so these experiences of sort of
encountering the people in your
environment
in silicon valley and stanford very true
very common
who are in fact part of the the sort of
um groundwork of
technology culture and that
that experience uh was one that inspired
uh in this case jim turner took to
have sukili sign one of the games and
frame it and then
uh uh have a series of artifacts that
sort of
appeared in similar fashion 3d printed
frames
in the seattle um technology museum
our final as design artifact
came out from just a simple remix of the
pac-man game itself wherein the students
designed
each of the pac-man elements
with the story of donna bailey in mind
donna bailey is again involved in the
centipedes development and
and organ and her story was
not only recorded in the in interview
pernell but also um recorded in
a kind of um a screenplay of sorts that
she recorded she
wrote out about uh almost by
autobiographical
time in her life so here we we used what
were
at once the cut scenes um where miss
pac-man married
pac-man instead replacing that with
her her script so she describes
for example she recorded for this game
the text on my first day at work i was
introduced to more than 50 guys
are they all dave i'll just call
everyone dave
so looking across these projects what
design
starts to do in this context is to be
understood
through the very process of writing
history or histography
so this is about seeing how we as hci
researchers can sort of work with
the the hidden elements of the novel
creations that that we intend to ascribe
to our own work
in the field and who is not credited but
also how those
non-credited elements can inform the
design of new spaces and practices
so it's really about a reading of the
work that that sort of cuts across
um two dimensions so on the one hand we
have the ability to garner significant
institutional
support publicity by thinking about
important stories
that have you know sort of escaped
the attention of of apollo or a gaming
enthusiast
um and bringing that back to the folks
in design that had that care most about
the representation of our field
on the other hand there are these ex
experiences of reading that are
are actually um full full
of potentials for objectification so
for example the feminization of an
engineering
context through metaphors of craft work
or a binary category of women
and we we turn this kind of complex and
written story
of under-recognized labor into
a series of objects so much figuratively
and literally
sort of um redefining these exclusions
now with these two stories you can see
that power of metaphor so
we are using metaphor here for shaping
what designers attend to
but also what they hide and this is the
the fraught
nature of this the kind of
analysis of a
historical approach design in the sense
that this is drawing our attention
to stakes in a way that can create
conditions for a reckoning
in reckoning i want to draw attention to
um
this idea that erasure is is
something to be constantly attended to
and re
revisited and what we mean by eraser
erasure
is is actually something very very
specifically in contrast
to a filling of gaps so
when when you speak about erasure as
refusing
that that ratification what we mean is
that where gaps exist as a thing in the
world but something
but erasure is is is is refusing to see
it as stable
or as persistent so it holds on to
action
it works as a verb erasure also resists
naturalizing a disappearance so where a
gap can be organic
a kind of silence of sorts and erasure
is a result of an intervention
erasure is also implicating its maker so
us designers or technologists where a
gap ignores agency in that way erasure
is recognizing not
just that act of doing right it's it's
um permitting naming the responsible
subject
erasure is also skewing this
assuming sorry the the sense of closure
or renewal so where i gather pairs
cleanly with sort of a fill or filling
the gap
an erasure just it does not imply that
clean ending or solution
and lastly erasure makes possible the
non-linear so
where we conceptualize um time and
progress
is something that is much more complex
and collective
in form um where a gap allows for
filling
a sequence and where you sure kind of
confounds that
that telling when you're telling
so if you recall donna bailey's film
script playing back over the atari women
pac-man game
you know for those audiences the
experience of co-workers appearing as
all daves are hovering over that moment
um and tension look this this
moment of punitive empowerment is
actually it's unsettling this division
between then
and we are doing this constantly in the
in in ungoingly in
our work of development with the atari
um sorry with the core memory project we
saw this happening
in the context of uh the retellings
the prod of of the mit museum's
um footage of the apollo guidance
computer where an interviewing
journalist observing the woman as
she doesn't have to think about which
court goes through next but jack
poundstone responds as a managing
uh raytheon director here um the machine
does that for her right no so this
idea of the women as i'm thinking
executors as code rather than inventive
contributors
is reverberating throughout these public
narratives of the apollo mission
but once you engage with the the sort of
practice
of creating the the story once again in
the present it becomes much harder for
us to feel this
and hold on to those perceptions
so understanding uh a
encounter with his historical inquiry
as vital to our experiences and design
means not keeping these two methods as
a separate and unique archival um
sort of encounters being vital to the
work we do
within any context of design
and it's sort of taking this lesson to
too many of the sort of design methods
we take
up in in the d-school context
this classic hexagon narrative whether
you
see it as a cycle or as a path you're
still
uh forced in in encounters with our
our sort of legacies of exclusion
and that are enshrined in design
classrooms and institutions to take
seriously the way
these processes are actually embedded in
structural inequities and reproducing
them along the way
a process that ends very much with one
of
erasure so for the projects that i've
shown you so far
sort of the most easily describable
method might be that assists
of speculative design these are not
creating
projects uh or products that that can be
taken
up and in in sort of
everyday life they're actually
encounters right and modes of
questioning
and speculative design has been of of
doing that work and
speculative um diagrams are often seen
in this way
as as tony dunn joe nureby's
diagram stuart can candy's work where
you see a present
right a one perspective dot and that dot
looks
out to the future of possible plausible
or probable
preferable being the sort of most
interesting red
red projection out there and that
preferable
is is is typically um
sort of placed without questioning who
decides
on what preferences are
now ebu krobek um
a textile artist has thought through the
ways in which
this possibilities cone might be
reversed and
in which we might be asking questions um
that also include
the influence of the past right and the
way that these openings analytic
openings could come from a process of
looking backward
but what we see throughout these these
projects today
is the ways in which whether a workshop
or classroom experience can actually
produce uh multiple perspectives
so what we're not seeing from one place
what we're seeing from
a cough of of
moments of of silence in a sense where
we see
we see those those ghostly traces
speaking in the present and that
disrupts the timeline
of of design so we're
we're essentially um always always
innovating by maintaining the status quo
and us needing to in intervene
in those in those trajectories
now i want to say this in the context of
current debates
in which um erasures are affecting
our departments our institutions in very
real ways
and in particular thinking about
how our um
kind of sort of uh
organize organizations of of of design
work and can allow for
for um shaping
our highest awards and accolades
including
the turning award as many of you have
weighed in on and explored and folks
that have
graduated from from your program have
noted
that um this week the sort of
communities we build the collective
lives that we
that we hold up as part of our computing
uh legacy are tied up in harmful
forms of exclusion and and um
and in fact these these things are are
reified in the design of awards
themselves
so again approaching these through
a more a
collective lens means also exploring
what other ways
we can tell new and different stories
and
i want to end with a kind of hope that
you consider
this the the standpoints you bring to
your field and
and the ideas for creating different
conditions accountabilities
across your work to be included in
the the kinds of publications
that we might build together as a
co-editor-in-chief of interactions
magazine we've been
looking specifically at different
tactics and abilities and connections
and how we might build the conditions
for what
cydia hartman would call impossible
story so with that i would love to take
your questions um and uh
yeah talk through any of the ideas you
have for building that
world together
so we have a question asking how do you
balance the rediscovery of history
versus the rewriting of history
yeah so many this is sort of the long
debate
uh amongst the historians of science but
also historians writ large right
it's the idea that history is is is not
a thing in the world that you find
but it's actively always made and
historiography is a term
for particularly recognizing that that
when we talk about history we're
actually also talking about it's
it's representation it's telling and
it's writing and that it's an active
process
of production so i wouldn't say that
there's a difference between those
in the sense that yes of course facts
are real
and things that uh i'm not not
uh trying to sort of elevate a
misinformation agenda what i am saying
though is that
even the the thing the events that
happen in the world can be told in
multiple ways
right and yes rewriting is part actually
of an active
reversing of power hierarchies or
inverting or challenging of
of particular knowledge um
knowledge hierarchies within fields of
computing and
wider discussions across
across science and technology fields
a lot of organizations um
and sig cut folks like that um
try to be inclusive by any people
and making sure that um the
awards committees and the conference
committees and so forth
include women include people from
you know all over the world and that
sort of thing
but that seems to um
make the smoothest path be something
that's
kind of similar to what we have now with
more voice
there but it doesn't change things as
fundamentally as some of your projects
have just you know done um a complete
rewrite on your you know mental model of
everything
um can you comment a little about how
um people trying to thing
can be truly inclusive rather than
just um like having more people in the
room but the room is the same
yeah i mean one thing there's so many
it's a great question
so first off um
i would say yes there's an allocation of
resources and it's super important to
just be clear
that uh there needs to be different
people
who you know have access to those
resources
right and that that that's just a fact
but how to do that and how to do that
in a way that matters and sustain is
sustainable etc um
that that's that's part of the question
so i think
you're on a conceptual level i think
that i
whole politics of inclusion sarah almond
makes this point nicely is
is tied up in the india there's an
includer and then included
right and so there's already a power
differential between those that are
making the choice as to who gets to be
in and who gets to be out
and and those people that are sort of
moved this way in that way
um and and of course this is not
deterministic
the people that that are included all
have
agency and and to reverse those tides
and to undo and challenge
those dynamics but just the politics of
inclusion tends to work
ultimately through that conceptual lens
right if there's
there there's you know the folks that
that are
organizing the awards and they might
like include someone in there and they
just make those choices
so how do you undo that and i think
that's that's kind of one
of the critical pieces of any
and this work is is that we need to
de-center the designer or de-center that
power figure uh
the kind of figure uh of the includer
and ultimately uh understand that that
those
folks making decisions need to be
representative
of the people that they are affecting
um and does that mean more elections
probably
right more people being uh
able to vote and choose who
are those representatives within sakai
within acm
um the elections themselves need to be
well organized i know there's been a lot
of hiccups this year for example
just sort of even registering to be a
part of that conversation
and have a voice so
um i'm essentially advocating for more
more processes that support democratic
exchange
i don't know if that answers your
question though do you have a sort of a
follow-up
not real it's just something that
puzzles me
um i suppose um as um
some of the traditionally excluded
people become
central the the main power figures
but we've we've had um you know women as
president of acm
and sheriff sid kai i'm pretty sure yeah
we have
um did that change anything
um don't know
um
yeah certainly not in humongous ways
um things have been you know getting
more
diverse and you know there's been more
diverse people included but it seems
like
it's real easy to just kind of slip
into um the old ways of doing things
and and the old set of people if you're
not
careful you'll you know the the first
dozen people that you nominate tend to
be white men
yeah i mean i i think the critical point
is that the
i the the folks that are probably able
to
to do the most
to change these institutional
arrangements are actually the
the same people that those institutions
forcibly disallow from having any
any control over the process so whoever
makes their way into the role
of president is typically someone who
has
very much been a part of that
institutional politics for a while and
and is not the ones that are complaining
and making a key
um kind of intervention within those
those frameworks
so yes i think there's a lot this is
much more structural than it is
about a single person able to to make a
change
we've got a question wondering how many
of the approaches to
representing a woman's stories he says
in tech and otherwise
um are have to address a perspective
that that's sort of about a relativity
to
men's stories and is wondering whether
there's a way to avoid that
yeah avoiding the relativity
to men's stories i think that's what the
question is trying to get at
um i mean one way to think of it is that
this is about sort of
intervening in patriarchy not about not
telling
men's stories um because it's not obvi
it's a not a binary relationship between
men and women this is about
any any minoritized person
whether they be um sort of a gender
minority or a racial
uh all the folk all the kinds of
divisions that get
sort of bifurcated as to how to
organize themselves as reproducing the
problem but i
i i think more importantly is really the
idea
that that it's it it isn't
again this this kind of framework of
inclusion or exclusion
that we need to worry about as much as
the
ways in which you do engage with
each of us when it comes to
people and positions of power engage
with those
those individuals and their work right
it's
does it mean that jeffrey allman should
never be spoken to or that his work
should never be engaged
perhaps not perhaps it's not about the
silencing of his
his agenda but about it grappling with
it and addressing
what it what harm it does in the world
what violence his
ideas have have kind of produced
um that is
sure yeah thank you the one i've been
curious about
is um you showed the
the d-school you call it path and
you know obviously the this notion of
speculative design
is taking you know its launch
its launching point is different and i'm
curious for you know students who have
approached me and others about
um how to
transition from a point of view that's
very influenced by sort of
human-centered design d-school thinking
and so on
into a world where they want to do work
like the kind of work that you're doing
um what which of the aspects of you know
the training that they might get
at a place like the d school here at
stanford can they hold on to and which
elements of it um do you
would do essentially we have to retrain
our brains around
yeah i mean the the
the ultimate question is what they're
hoping to achieve
right are they hoping to generate
questions are they hoping to
organize uh their their
work around issues and and have
a kind of stake in those issues and
affect communities that they're working
with
or are they hoping to build a product
that sells on the market
um those are very different goals
um i'm not saying that all d-school
product our issues are
about uh products but i think much of
the product development cycle is
organized in a way that
sort of prioritizes um
the economic needs uh or
or prioritizes the the capacity for
these to turn a profit
um as opposed to potentially listening
to
the the concerns of of folks that
that are very vocal about what they
desire or want
and and need and and organizing a
product that would fit those
um those particular issues and that
i i think the speculative piece is
particularly around
what is possible or impossible within
those frameworks so
really questioning reading and and
and um producing new
frameworks for for addressing
those needs and desires and and
underserved
um kind of capacities for
computation to to work in the world so i
think the
there's a lot that that speculation
does in its current form um but it's not
some sort of
um package deal where it's sort of
uh i guess as it's as its practice in
hci
can very much be also just speaking to a
very small group of people but
publishing together and writing together
and not affecting the world outside it
so i'd say that that connection with the
world is the most vital part whether you
take up a human-centered
design process or a speculative design
process
how you kind of engage with those
those affected by the work you do
right yeah and definitely human center
does not have to be in
uh in contention with being speculative
yeah i i'm going to jump to a question
from uh
an undergraduate i believe and then
maybe one of the phd students
uh i'd love to give a chance for one of
the phd students to to jump in
uh so if any of you have thoughts it
will be a good moment
asking a very practical question how
how you recommend that individual
college students can make an impact for
the cause
so from the perspective that you know
the kind of work that you're doing
what would be the you know what would be
the steps you'd recommend for them
so stanford students in general
or sure yep pic pick your pick your
your pick anyway yeah yeah sure okay
yeah
no um i mean it's it's a great question
because anyone
anyone can take up design methods in
different ways right if
they so choose in the sense that you
have the time and
ability to do so um and what what
i think a student perspective offers in
many ways
is the ability to look outside the
constraints of of
your faculty that um might be responding
to
pressures for ten-year pressures for
recognition
especially at police like stanford
junior faculty
um might need to conform to certain
kinds of questions that they're asking
and in fact
what you can bring is attention to
what is at stake in each of these
projects why does it
why does this intellectual work matter
how can
you professor or or um
i guess i'm think i'm focusing this very
much in the research direction but i
think it can be true outside it as well
um you know the the kinds of ways that
you're
that your internships and and industry
or your
engagements with uh people
that you meet alongside of your
coursework
uh everyone has a stake in technology
development and
what's what is that a great how can you
learn
and better inform yourself as you make
your way through
your curriculum and each of those
relationships i think
proves vital to the kinds of impacts you
make
thank you i endorse that answer
uh yeah i had a question thanks so much
for your talk
i really enjoyed listening and the
projects are fascinating i was wondering
if you can talk a little bit more about
how you discover those metaphors
for example the metaphor of craft was so
powerful
the way that shifts the way you think
about the process
and i'm curious to know how you arrive
at those metaphors
is it something you start with or
something you discover in the process as
you're
learning more and archiving more
yeah it's a great question i think um
you know we're always using metaphors in
in
how we kind of encounter technology and
and and or even just various aspects of
our research we're probably always using
these shorthand ways of thinking about
um
things and for me that has come very
much out of
the the kinds of activities that that
i've
found challenge my relationship to
computing so textiles
has been a long-standing crafts and
textiles
um kind of metaphors have been a
long-standing focus
of of the work i've done um but
uh you know they keep reappearing in
interesting ways
in ways i don't expect so for example um
a project in a class that i'm teaching
that's called on the bias and it's very
much about the
you know the ways in which we experience
systemic harms through and
[Music]
with the technologies that we produce at
but as as a um
sort of encounter with the way you cut
on the bias if you're a textile producer
so we're thinking about
the bias itself as also a
skew as it's as it's sort of articulated
in textile
um at the textile metaphor
bias being one which you turn fabric and
it creates
a sort of a powerful soft drape you can
create a head scar
that you can produce a cloth diaper you
can do particular things with bias in
the textile world and that
is an example again of another metaphor
that for me has
i mean it keeps keeps coming back as a
generative space to think with as you
imagine the that the reorientation
of a concept like bias can actually
um allow us to see also the the
generative aspects of
attending to um difference affirmative
action right as a form of
of of specific form of aggressive
using um bias for for reparations
so i think there's um yeah there's a lot
of ways in which metaphors kind of
come about naturally in quotes
through this everyday encounters with
their environment and
sort of looking at what they open up and
what they sort of foreclose for the kind
of
analytic work you're doing so i guess as
we're coming up on 11 o'clock at a
friday night for daniella
uh why don't we all thank her for
joining us uh and for
very cool work and we uh
we hope to see you back in
the bay area at some point uh we would
love to meet you in person
um until then we will we will make
ourselves uh
satisfied with with what we've got on
zoom so thanks again so much for joining
us
and for giving us a late night talk oh
thank you so much for having me and for
all the questions
i really appreciate it